all right joining me now is horse Cooper
co-chair of project 21 and Michael
schellenberger author of San Francisco
why progressives ruined cities gentlemen
thanks for joining me Horace I want to
come to you first what is your reaction
to What Kevin Cork just told us
well I'm outraged this tells us all that
we need to know about how the wokesters
when they're handling prosecution how
they're not putting the victims as their
priority a child was assaulted by this
individual that ought to be where the
conversation begins and the conversation
ends now we know from a Cold Case record
that this person actually is involved
perhaps in the death of another person
and as the report indicated had a
lengthy arrest record we shouldn't be so
concerned about hurting the feelings of
these uh Predators we ought to be making
sure they're put in a place where they
can never attack again shame on gascon
shame on these prosecutors because they
don't realize the overwhelming number of
the victims that are harmed are are the
kinds of people that don't have the
wherewithal to protect themselves are to
protect their children
Michael you're a California guy and to
hear a horse's point you have gascon who
is more concerned about a D.A or
assistant D.A who's offending a trans
child molester that he is about a actual
trans child molester
well that's right I mean it appears in
this case the prosecutor who was fired
by gascon was fired as retribution for
pointing out the fact that the suspect
actually bragged of having tricked
people into treating him as a trans
woman and so there's a real question
here about whether this is truly
somebody who identifies as trans or
whether this is just a scam to get into
a woman's prison this may seem like an
obscure issue but in fact the prime
minister of Scotland just resigned over
the last few of the last week because
she had allowed prisoners to
self-identify into whichever gender they
wanted and in one case they sent a male
convict into a woman's prison and it set
off an uproar in the country so it's
both the kind of marriage of the two
worst worlds one is a kind of radical
wokism as it relates to criminal justice
and the other one is as a kind of
radical gender ideology which allows
anybody to to claim to be whatever
gender they want even in the case of
prisoners facing a possibility of going
to a woman's prison yeah it's
unbelievable all right Horace let's move
to St Louis oh go ahead
just want to say this we are giving
attention to this felon
when we should make the central focus on
the victim and my biggest criticism my
biggest criticism of these Sorrows
funded prosecutors is that they act as a
publicly funded defense attorney for
those that prey on the rest of the
innocent we need to turn back and hold
these Bad actors accountable the more
punishment the more penalty the greater
it is the fewer Bad actors you'll see
listen I used to prosecute these cases
as a D.A and these these victims of of
child sexual assault you ruin lives for
a lifetime it's a lifetime absolutely
horrible all right I want to give you
guys this take on this because we're
speaking of woke Soros back prosecutors
Missouri attorney general has moved to
fire the city's prosecutor Kim Gardner
after a teenager lost both of her legs
in a crash that police says was caused
by a robbery suspect who had violated
Bond conditions Michael this seems like
a a proactive decision to finally go
after these corrupt prosecutors by state
officials what do you say
I think it's a very interesting thing in
fact what we see both in Los Angeles and
in St Louis is you see people resisting
the woke prosecution agenda speaking out
for the first time in the case of
Missouri the AG is attempting to remove
the district attorney from Office what
that district attorney has done is the
same thing that radical process
radically Progressive prosecutors have
done in San Francisco and Los Angeles
which is basically to let people out not
require that people be held in jail for
alleged crimes and the result is repeat
offenses I mean the one in St Louis the
the guy in question had violated
the electronic monitoring 50 times
before the accident so I mean you have
this just repeat offensive and you have
these district attorneys that are
basically acting like like defense
attorneys rather than as prosecutors and
so look these are also cities I should
mention that are lacking hundreds of
police officers crime is absolutely out
of control homicides remain at record
levels their needs to be serious
prosecution of serious crimes but horse
we now see the
mime explodes in community
would elect these George Soros back DA's
and completely destroy their communities
explain that to me
we're seeing fundraising explode
especially when Sorrows backed
organizations and think tanks are able
to pour in the kinds of resources that
turn a D.A race into something like a
congressional race shame on the left who
used to claim that when you put money
into politics that it ruined things and
they've set back there's this second
problem of these wilkesters and that is
that rich people and Elites and the well
to do they move to other communities
they can hire security but the very
people that rely most on the criminal
justice system are the ones that lose
when these Soros prosecutors get their
way so true gentlemen thanks for joining
me I appreciate it hey Sean Hannity here
hey click here to subscribe to Fox News
YouTube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else